vendredi soir place des arts duceppe
présente la pièce héritage à guichets
fermés
près de 800 spectateurs et un détail qui
saute aux yeux c'est pas la première
fois comme un chef du cep qui est ça
fait du bien le voir un public plus
jeune et plus colorée c'est la première
fois qu'un théâtre institutionnel
francophones québécois présente une
production avec une distribution
majoritairement noirs résultat des
centaines de personnes des communautés
noires
ils sont allés en groupe en famille ou
entre amis la troupe et noir donc ça ne
rejoint plus la communauté et qui fait
que ça nous rejoint cru c'est avec
l'argent qu'on peut ça me faire des
changements si on met notre notre
intérêt nos intentions sont ou qu'est-ce
qu'on veut voir de plus dans le monde
artistique mais pour supporter soci
c'est une ouverture
les comédiens ont eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec des membres du public
c'est fou c'est vraiment des témoignages
de gens heureux cette super content
soulagé de pouvoir se voir sur une pièce
peu importe les origines des spectateurs
les critiques sont positives
ça nous touche à la mesure où comme
québécois il ya peut-être pu y avait
peut-être quelque chose qui vivait ben
nous aussi
dans cette pièce c'est l'adaptation
c'est rassembleur héritage a donné un
coup d'envoi fulgurant à la saison 2 du
cep
quand même 7800 abonnés quasiment huit
mille cette année on espère toujours
vendre environ 4000 billets individuels
et plus pour ce spectacle on en a vendu
7300 fait quand même énorme le port
des chiffres qui envoie un message clair
aux directions théâtre si le ps veut des
gens dans sa salle et vous déjà
diversifié basta pourtant la mecque je
pense que ce passé chute c'est un
travail de longue haleine pour fidéliser
un public
longtemps oublié ici valérie michaela
bayne rate aucun mandat morial